Ngày mũ chiến tháng 2 năm 2018, kêu tưởng trên thành đất chỉ hí triệu bộ đội việt phòng thành phố Xí Minh cho biết,
đơn vị với chủ gì, phối hộn với các đơn vị, lực lượng trức năng trị phá thình công chuyên an số HC122 sau,
bác sự mỗi đối tượng có hình vi tảng trữ trải phép tình ra.
Chứ đó, lúc mấy bún dựa 3 mưu nè mình tám tháng 2 năm 2018,
tại không được phương tình phố Xí Minh, lượng lượng trức năng phát hiện bác có tăng phán mọc bảo phúc,
xin năm 2018, chú phòng phù mí, tình phố Xí Minh có hình vi tảng trữ trải phép tình Việt ngang ra.
Tại hiện chương lượng lượng trức năng trữ 2 mưu năng trâm mi đường diền Việt Nam,
trong đó có 2 mưu sáo tượng mạnh giá năm 2018, có năm số xíu khách nhau,
bố mấy tưu tượng mạnh giá 2020, có một số xíu ý phôn mềm một mổ đọc.
Phúc tượng nhận tất cả số tình trên là tình Việt Nam sản gió phúc tự làm và mang đi bán thi bị lượng lượng trức năng phát quá tăng.
Tức tục đấu tranh, phúc hay nhận đã làm được tổng cộng 3 mưu ba trị đồng diền Việt Nam sản và đã bán cho bố đường lượng,
mới tổng số tiền là 152,000 đồng. Thế thì liện bán bón trị đồng diền Việt Nam sản thí thu tình một trị đồng diền Việt Nam thật.
Hàm xét hình cấp đưa ở của phân gọc bảo phúc, lượng lượng trức năng trữ giữa thi bị vảng hưu lượng vùng,
một mấy ím mổ hiệu khăn hông cẹn hộng bật, một mấy ím nhật, một mặc bóng vầy và tăng bật khác có linh quán.
Hệ, đơn vị đà phối hộp với các lượng trức năng đưa trà, sử lý theo quy định của pháp lần.